hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar no pressure
HPLC the analytical alternative for
charged and polar analytes presented by
dr. Vince
Remco a professor of chemistry and
materials science at Oregon State
University i'm susie valdez elaborate
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by psychics to learn more about our
sponsor please visit them at SCI XCOM
now let's get started I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
spend we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
simply click on the support tab found at
the top right of your presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offered continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
dr. Vince REM show a professor of
chemistry and materials science at
Oregon State University for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen welcome dr. REM show you may now
begin your presentation great thanks
very much Suzy I am grateful for the
opportunity to share some thoughts and
insights on the topic of doing HPLC or
HPLC alternatives with no pressure so
thank you again let's get started
I'd like to begin by offering up some
rather typical analytical lab situations
that actually fit in many other parts of
life as well first one would be trying
to do everything with just one
technology we tend to be driven by the
technologies that are available to us in
our own laboratories right now and
sometimes don't open our minds to
alternatives that might fit better
so rather than one-size-fits-all
considering a different approach to
solving an analytical problem a second
typical situation might be not having
enough time to do it right the first
time which forces us to do things over
and over again it's always better to try
to do it the best way the first time if
that's at all possible a third scenario
is developing a transferable method just
ensuring that the method that we develop
can be transferred to a QA QC
environment to maximum good effect so
that things don't have to generate a ton
of questions that might come back to a
method development lab and cause another
iteration to have to occur so best to
develop a really truly transferable
method with a small number of variables
that are fixed at good values from the
beginning and then the final typical
analytical lab situation might be not
really factoring in the actual costs and
opportunity cost to your organization
that arise from not having the best
alternative to an analytical technique
when we launch into doing a particular
kind of chemical analysis so the way
we're going to try to address these
typical analytical lab situations is
through some case studies so this is
called scenario based learning and it
basically involves presenting an actual
situation and then a solution or set of
solutions to that particular problem and
it's a great way to learn so we're going
to look at four different actual
situations the first one focuses on an
agricultural crop and export from the
u.s. to Europe that was misidentified as
having been contaminated with a
particular pesticide the second
scenario is an actual situation again
where too much time was being eaten up
in developing and running a set of
analytical methods in biopharma and it
might have been easier to solve the
problem using a different technology the
third scenario was a milk powder protein
adulteration study a situation is
probably familiar from the news where an
infant formula was adulterated with a
different protein than was intended to
have been included in the first place
and then in the interest of time we'll
skip ahead to the next and final
scenario which is identifying a
particular kind of biomolecule and/or
bioactive molecule and Optima very very
rapidly from a large mixture of
candidate Optimas for a target analyte
so these will be examples there of
course many other analytical challenges
as well but let's look at these four
with a little bit of detail and we'll
start with a u.s. agricultural export
and the particular export is walnuts
tree nuts that were intended to have
been exported from California to the EU
so in Europe pesticide controls and
pesticide regulations are different than
they are in the u.s. in Europe faasil
aluminium is not an allowed pesticide
and in December of 2013
particular wall nut shipment to the EU
from California was found to have a
faasil residue so it wasn't faceted
aluminum that was detected it was
phosphonic acid phosphonate that was
detected so the conclusion was made that
phosphate aluminum must have been used
as a pesticide on the walnuts but in
point of fact that wasn't the case so an
analytical method that was more directly
focused on analysis of fawcett aluminum
would have been a preferred approach the
method that was used was ion suppression
chromatography it's a fantastically
useful technology an HPLC method
where we adjust the pH of the element to
suppress the ionization of in this
instance phosphoric acid and phosphonic
acid in order to allow them to be
separated chromatographic we using a
reverse phase method but you notice that
both of these acids even when they're
fully protonated at low pH are still
small molecules so they're not very
strongly retained on a reverse phase
column when we're doing ion suppression
chromatography for that reason we see
great variability in retention time and
the chart on the left demonstrates this
for phosphonate the retention times
varied over time you see some blanks in
there as well and also for phosphate you
see variations in retention time so this
can lead to miss identification which is
not desirable on the right hand side you
see a calibration curve and you notice
that the calibration curve is quite
linear
when standards are prepared in a solvent
but when we're looking at extracts from
Speight samples of various different
nuts that we don't have a very good
linear response over the desired range
from close to zero parts per million to
up to 20 parts per million there's great
deviation from linearity so an
alternative approach to doing this
analysis an alternative suppression
chromatography would have been capillary
zone electrophoresis and what you'll
notice immediately on the bottom-left
chart is that migration times were much
more reproducible for both phosphonate
and phosphate in addition on the right
hand side you notice that the
calibration curve is much more linear
for the extract samples for the
standards that were prepared by spiking
nut samples and then extracting them the
linearity was much improved over the
range of concentration studied when
capillary electrophoresis was the method
of choice so this allowed for more
positive identification of what the
contaminants were and therefore it was
possible to source those contaminants to
identify where they had come from and
therefore
continue with the export so that can
result in quite a substantial savings
addition to cost savings we can save
time in developing and running
analytical methods if we are careful to
select the right analytical methodology
so let's look at a different case here
we're going to look at charge
heterogeneity and biopharmaceuticals
therapeutic SAR growing in popularity
and growing in their positive effects on
human and animal health when we look at
a protein therapeutic though there are
many different kinds of concerns that we
might have and many different kinds of
analyses we may be interested in doing
we might be interested in looking at
protein fragments and there are many
great analytical technologies for doing
that including slab gel electrophoresis
reversed-phase hplc or potentially
capillary electrophoresis in addition we
might be interested in aggregates of
proteins or in charge variants or in the
potency of a particular protein
therapeutic many other possibilities as
well let's look in particularly though
at charge variants with charge variants
the goal would be to consider as many
drug candidates and manufacturing
conditions as possible initially but
increase the rule-out rates so that we
can narrow this down to really strong
drug candidates as quickly as possible
earlier decisions that are enabled
through more comprehensive data will
allow us to more rapidly bring a new
product to market and prevent us from
eliminating something that is a
potential drug candidate a strong drug
candidate by erroneously looking at too
little data so our goal is to develop
high-throughput analytical tools
so in a particular case of protein
therapeutics and in particular charge
variants our alternatives of
consideration might be ion exchange
chromatography capillary isoelectric
focusing in capillary zone
electrophoresis so when we talk about
charge heterogeneity what we're talking
about is small variations in charge and
in this particular case we're looking at
the c-terminal lysine heterogeneity that
might be possible in an antibody a
therapeutic antibody one mechanism for
looking at that particular heterogeneity
is through ion exchange chromatography
broadly utilized very powerful technique
in this particular methodology the
positively charged protein would
interact with the negatively charged
packing material or sorbent and the
negatively charged species would flow
through more rapidly so there'd be a
difference in retention time between the
two different analytes in developing a
modern ion exchange method we need to
control the ionic strength of the buffer
the pH of the buffer that we're using as
an element we may be interested in
running a gradient in either ionic
strength or pH we'd want to control
obviously the flow rate and the column
temperature we have to carefully select
the sorbent that we're going to use from
any of a handful of different column
manufacturers so many different
variables to control so optimization for
instance with this National Institute
for Standards and Technology monoclonal
antibody as a target to test analyte or
just a case study analyte we have many
different variables to consider again
the salt gradient that we may use to an
ionic strength gradient or a pH gradient
and each of these is going to give us
control over the analytical outcome they
will help us to optimize the separation
so that we can separate acidic variants
from basic variants relative to the main
or target analyte the target
therapeutics that
line two isolate so many different
variables that would have to be
optimized using careful design of
experiment as we generate an ion
exchange method and this might be a
typical result for this NIST monoclonal
antibody
an alternative that has a different set
of variables that we would need to
control would be capillary isoelectric
focusing so isoelectric focusing is
generally considered to be one of the if
not the highest resolution separation
techniques available in the modern
market so this is a capillary based
separation technique where we establish
a pH gradient within the capillary we
would apply the sample turn on the power
supply and analytes are separated by
migrating in the direction of their
isoelectric point to their p i-- when
they arrive at that point in the pH
gradient they essentially stop and if
they diffuse in one direction or the
other
they then pick up a small amount of
charge because they're now in a
different pH region and that causes them
to migrate right back to their P I once
again so they're very sharply focused at
their isoelectric point the pH of course
corresponds to that within the pH
gradient and once again you can see that
we can get a great separation of this
NIST monoclonal antibody that
demonstrates that the primary component
is that main peak at the center the very
tall peak that goes off scale and it
separates the acidic from the basic
species once again
so a very similar outcome to what we saw
with ion exchange chromatography but
once again many different variables to
consider the handful light mixture the
manufacturer the agent that produced
those analytes any additives that we may
need to use for instance a denatured or
spacers and then the focusing time the
time we allow the experiment to evolve
so it could be important to consider a
different kind of scenario for this
particular separation and alternative
technology that has fewer parameters
that need to be optimized and therefore
fewer places where a mistake can be made
in particular when a method is
transferred from the method development
lab into the QA QC environment the two
parameters for this other method
capillary electrophoresis would be just
the buffer pH and identity and if we
chose the addition of any zwitterionic
additives
one of the great beauties of considering
a capillary electrophoresis method is
that a number of kits of all the
reagents that are necessary are already
available for a series of different
kinds of analyses this takes up much of
the solution prep component of the
entire separative process and allows us
to rely on premade solutions that make
the separation much much easier to
reproduce as we move through periods of
great periods of time so another benefit
of looking at capillary electrophoresis
is that its efficiency and resolution
are nearly as good as capillary
isoelectric focusing so here the CIE
separation that you see is almost as
good as the isoelectric focusing
separation but there are fewer variables
to control and therefore reproducibility
can be greatly improved in fact as we
compare seee to other alternatives like
isoelectric focusing and ion exchange
chromatography you'll note that it is
capable of operating on a wide variety
of platforms that it has a total
analysis time that is as short as or
shorter than most of the alternatives it
offers excellent resolution and it
allows us to get detection limits that
rival those that we're able to achieve
with other techniques so clearly a very
viable methodology
so seee has been validated across many
different sites for many different
applications including a monoclonal
antibody application like the one you
just saw that's true because seee has
been demonstrated to be a very robust
technique a very reliable technique and
again has been employed to good effect
using the same target analytes in
multiple different laboratories with
similar or comparable results so let's
move on to just another application
example and this would be milk powder
additives or adulteration of infant
formula or powdered milk through the
addition of whey protein or soy protein
so it's important to be able to identify
these because these are allergens
potentially for many individuals it
turns out powdered milk because it's a
very complex mixture is easily
adulterated and it can be adulterated
most commonly with either way or soy
protein whey is just the leftover liquid
from cheese production it's a waste
product that does have high protein
content and therefore is quite valuable
if it's not used as an adulterant and
instead as an intended additive to a
milk product soy protein could be an
additive of great utility also we're
diluting milk or fortifying milk but soy
allergies are quite common especially in
toddlers and infants if we contaminate a
milk product with whey or soy protein
there are many different kinds of
effects that could occur including
nausea thirst bloating cramps and all
kinds of unhappiness for both the small
child and for the parents so identifying
whether the protein content of a
particular formula is as it was intended
is very important and again because milk
is very complex and difficult to analyze
we need a very high resolution
analytical technique in order to do the
analysis of milk
some common analytical options for this
kind of analytical issue would be gel
electrophoresis or high-performance
liquid chromatography gel
electrophoresis is inexpensive but it's
relatively low resolution has limited
quantitative capability and is very
manual very labor intensive HPLC on the
other hand offers automation very high
resolution but has the drawback of many
variables to adjust a selection of
solvents gradients columns and column
chemistry's and of course sample
preparation a very powerful technique
that does require expertise a very
straightforward high resolution
alternative is capillary zone
electrophoresis and in 2018 a really
informative article is published in the
Journal of the association of official
analytical chemists international a OAC
international demonstrating that
capillary electrophoresis is readily
capable of separating low molecular
weight whey protein additives into milk
and whey additives of high molecular
weight into milk from the casein
component
you
the method was recognized in 2019 as the
2018 method of the year capillary
electrophoresis for this particular
separative
need
and capillary
is now the standard we're analyzing milk
powder imports into Mexico so with
respect to the international market see
he has demonstrated its capability its
reproducibility and its value as a good
alternative to analytical technique to
HPLC ion exchange and gel
electrophoresis let's look at one final
case study or scenario and that is the
search for an Optima that has a high
binding constant for a particular
target analyte typically this is a very
time-consuming search so an app demur is
a and all ago typically an
oligonucleotide but sometimes in all ago
peptide that has higher order structure
that allows it to bind strongly to a
target analyte the way that we identify
a p-- Demers is by starting with a
random library of ala goes and screening
them against the target analyte and
selecting only those that have a very
high binding constant for that target
analyte the beauty of apt immerse is
that they are non toxic and non
immunogenic they have very predictable
pharmacokinetics once they've been
identified they're relatively easily
prepared in bulk at relatively low cost
they have a long shelf life and are very
stable and because they are developed
synthetically they can target toxins or
other analytes that don't necessarily
generate an immune response and
therefore aren't good candidates for the
development of antibodies in an animal
system
another beauty is that they often will
refold after they're exposed to
denaturing conditions this means that we
can use them to bind very selectively
something from solution and then
purposely denature them to release what
they've bound and then refold them and
reuse them they're also very useful for
simple antidote generation for various
different toxins so for that reason the
identification of apt immerse from these
large random libraries is a very
important task although it is a
difficult task
seelix is a family of technologies that
are among the most commonly used to
identify high binding constant optimism
random libraries and two of the most
popular methodologies there are the use
of a nitrocellulose membrane filtration
based selects process which allows us to
independently separate after several
selection rounds typically up to 12 a
target after mer that i that has a high
binding constant for our target analyte
another possibility is the use of
affinity chromatography and/or magnetic
bead based selects and in this instance
we would take our target analyte and
immobilize it on an affinity reagent and
then screen against that affinity column
the entire library of Optimas so this
requires immobilizing the target analyte
and therefore it's a difficulty if the
target lacks an affinity tag that allows
us to easily immobilize it so for that
reason it would be great if we could
screen without having to immobilize the
target analyte and it is possible to do
that and Mike Bowser
at the University of Minnesota was one
of the very first to demonstrate this
that this is possible so his selects
method uses capillary electrophoresis a
high-speed technique high resolution
technique with a reasonable peak
capacity that allows for minimal sample
dilution and allows for the
identification of an optimum from an
optimal library that
selectively binds a particular target
analyte so as you see on Mike's slide he
was able to identify a number of key
advantages to the Cee Cee Lex approach
view around the selection are necessary
there's a lower opportunity for
nonspecific interactions few of any non
binding sequences the ability to target
small targets in free solution without
having to immobilize them and the great
possibility for automation because we
have C systems that are now very well
automated from a variety of vendors so
it's useful for separations of small
molecules to large proteins dramatically
faster and requires only two to four
rounds of C Lex vs. many more rounds and
the other technologies that I just
shared with you this can save quite a
lot of time so I hope what you've seen
is a capillary electrophoresis is a
really powerful technique and an
alternative to HPLC but I want to speak
to this idea of no pressure HPLC in
high-performance liquid chromatography
we drive our mobile phase through the
system by using a pressure gradient that
generates a flow profile that
distributes analyte zones more broadly
than would be ideal in a capillary
electrophoresis system be it a cz II
system and a me KC system or even a CEC
system our flow profile is very flat is
essentially the same flow velocity cross
sectionally across the entire capillary
that is less dispersive it results in
much sharper Peaks and much higher
efficiency so see separates based on
differential migration in an electric
field it's the ratio of the charge of
our analyte to its hydrodynamic volume
that allows us to resolve different
components from one another the two most
common variants of cer capillary gel
electrophoresis and capillary zone
electrophoresis but there are other
alternatives that are much closer to
HPLC in how they operate but they do use
the exact same instrumentation as
capillary zone electrophoresis a very
simple system that's readily automated
and that takes advantage of the low
volume of a fused silica capillary in
order to do a very high resolution
separation and these two techniques are
micellar electro kinetic capillary
chromatography in which we use a
surfactant present in the mobile phase
at a concentration above its critical
micelle concentration so that we form
transient micelles these micelles form
and fall apart but they're together long
enough for analytes to be able to
partition into the hydrophobic core and
back out so in addition to the electro
phoretic migration component that can
lead to separation of charged analytes
we find that M ekc allows us to separate
species that are neutral by partitioning
them between two phases which is a
chromatographic form of separation so
here we have both an electro phoretic
and a chromatographic separation
occurring at the same time with no
external pressure applied to the system
another variant is capillary
electrochromic ography which many groups
have studied and my group made some
contributions a number of years ago to
the study of capillary electric roma tog
Rafi here instead of using my cells to
provide assortment for a chromatographic
separation we use a packing material the
same kinds of packing materials that
were customed to using in
high-performance liquid chromatography
but we use electro osmosis as the motive
force for bulk transport and because we
are using electro osmosis it's a very
flat flow profile and we get all the
efficiency advantages here that we would
get in any other capillary electrospray
technique so that allows us to do once
again HPLC with no pressure as an
alternative using the exact same kinds
of instruments that we use for capillary
electrophoresis
so there are many different applications
for this family of seee techniques that
include c e m EK c and c ec and many
other technologies as well and these
applications are in pharma and biopharma
in many different applied markets
including the AG bio market and many
other applications that have been
developed in academic laboratories that
have yet to be realized in a production
environment but have the potential to be
realized there so I hope what you've
seen is that it is possible to use
capillary electrophoresis as an
alternative to HPLC as an alternative to
ion exchange as an alternative to gel
electrophoresis or even izo electric
focusing and to use it to really good
effect so that you can solve common
analytical problems in the laboratory to
much greater effect and with that I'll
close and we'll gladly take your
questions
you
you
thank you dr. REM Cho for your
informative presentation and we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's get started
looks like we have some incoming
questions from our audience now Vince
what kind of detectors are available for
capillary electrophoresis systems well
Susie I'm glad that question got passed
along the most popular option and kind
of the standard for detection in a seee
system is a UV vis detector but
photodiode array detectors are available
as our laser induced fluorescence
detectors and even electrospray
ionisation interfaces to mass
spectrometers are available which adds
quite a bit of additional analytical
power to the seee instrument remember
too you can use that see instrument for
more than just capillary zone
electrophoresis you can use it for any
Casey you can use it for CEC you can use
it for isoelectric focusing so lots of
different applications and your choice
of detector in part is predicated on
which of those mechanisms you are most
interested in using for your particular
analytical problem Thank You Vic and our
mass spec interfaces available for these
systems they are indeed like I said the
most popular one is the electrospray
ionisation interface Phi X has a CESI
system that that is a very well
developed alternative within the field
of possibilities so I encourage people
to consider that but again if we're
going to interface to a mass
spectrometer we have to be careful about
what mechanism of separation we're going
to to choose to use if we're going to do
Emmy KC for instance that requires a lot
of extra care because we don't want to
introduce the surfactant to the mass
spectrometer so much more popular to use
the capillary zone electrophoresis
when we're interfacing to a mass spec
thank you and our next question from our
audience number is is the quantitative
reproductive ability of capillary
electrophoresis as good as it is for
HPLC great question the quantitative
reproducibility of seee
can be quite good due to the automation
of the injection step the qualitative
reproducibility can be equally good to
HPLC one of the great strengths of
liquid chromatography is that we use a
six port sample valve with a sample loop
to introduce the sample so it's a fixed
volume if we inject a full ORD make a
full loop injection in c e we're using
either an electro kinetic sample
introduction methodology or pressure of
vacuum based injection methodology so
it's very easy to vary the volume but
reproducibility sometimes won't be quite
as good quantitatively for c ii as it is
for HPLC but the beauty of it is the
technique is very rapid so we get around
the problem by running many replicants
several replicants often in less time
than it takes to run one sample by HPLC
and that gives us good statistical
control over quantitative
reproducibility
thank you and thank you to our audience
members for these great questions coming
in our next question is what steps have
to be taken to ensure that the
qualitative reproducibility of seee is
optimized
well qualitative reproducibility really
has to do with retention time or in the
case of capillary zone electrophoresis
migration time reproducibility so for
that what we need to do is make sure
that we've conditioned the capillary
properly before a given run a very
typical routine would be at the
beginning of the analysis day to do an
extensive itching and flushing of the
capillary if it's a non modified
capillary that is it's a modified Kapler
than their washing procedures that are
particular to that particular chemistry
but for a non surface modified capillary
we would H and rinse and then run some
standards and then a mild action rinse
and samples and then periodically run
standards throughout the day and if we
follow that protocol then qualitative
rubadoux's reproducibility migration
time reproducibility becomes quite good
Thank You Ven one
number writen I have read about
discrimination in seee sample
introduction is this a universal problem
or is there a solution to it oh this is
directly related to the previous
question so I'm glad it came along so
discrimination is the introduction of
one analyte in a sample preferentially
to other components of the sample and
this happens when we're making an
injection with a variety of different
charged analytes that have differing
electro phoretic mobilities so those
with the strongest electro phoretic
mobilities in the direction of the field
that's being applied to the capillary
those will be introduced in the highest
concentration mode rapidly so that's
basically like the start of a footrace
at the beginning of the race those
runners who are naturally the fastest
will move more rapidly down the course
and towards the finish line and those of
us who are a little slower will be
introduced not quite as preferentially
so that kind of discrimination can be
avoided if instead of an electro kinetic
injection we make a pressure or a vacuum
based injection in which everything is
introduced very uniformly and with the
automation and modern sea instruments
that's a very easy thing to do
Thank You Vince and we have what time
for one more question from our audience
you mentioned Hector MERS can be used
instead of antibodies and and do induce
immune response can they be used as
vaccines
Oh super interesting question well
outside of my area of expertise I do
know there's great interest in using apt
immerse therapeutically but again not
being an immunologist it's just outside
of my field of study you know the
interesting thing about apt immerse from
an analytical perspective is their
tremendous selectivity they really do
rival antibodies in their selectivity
and because of that they make great
immuno chromatographic sorbents and so
for medical diagnostic purposes they
have tremendous potential and that makes
them once again a really great fit for
electrokinetic separations for
techniques that have an inherently high
peak capacity that are good for looking
at really complex samples great question
and thank you audience members for those
great questions that you brought in and
since would you like to provide a
closing remark for the audience before
we leave today absolutely I'd like to
start by just thanking Sikes for the
opportunity to share some thoughts and
ideas it's been a great pleasure to
focus on some true case scenarios some
real analytical problems that have been
solved using pretty innovative
analytical technologies so I'm grateful
for that but most of all at socks I want
to thank Peter hopper and Hans Dewald
for their great support and Matt Salem
for his support as well and thank you
Susie for hosting today of course and
I'd like to once again thank you for
your time and your important research
I'd also like to think lab roots and our
sponsors ix4 underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we didn't have time
for today and those submitted during
on-demand registration will be addressed
by dr. rim Stowe via email address be
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share this email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event you will be redirected now to
the registration page of our next Phi X
webinar titled widely applicable charge
variant analysis of therapeutic proteins
presented by Peter Cooper application
scientist at Phi X this webinar will be
broadcast live on February 28th at 9
a.m. Pacific time we hope to see you
there bye bye